geneva russian foreign minister lavrov
and i met to discuss the crisis
instigated by russia's military buildup
on ukraine's borders
and steps to de-escalate tensions and
pursue diplomacy
russia had previously outlined its
concerns and proposals in writing and
last week i told foreign minister lavrov
the united states would do the same
today
master sullivan delivered our written
response in moscow
all told it sets out a serious
diplomatic path forward should russia
choose it
the document we've delivered includes
concerns of the united states and our
allies and partners about russia's
actions that undermine security
a principled and pragmatic evaluation of
the concerns that russia has raised and
our own proposals for areas where we may
be able to find common ground
we make clear that there are core
principles that we are committed to
uphold and defend
including ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and the right of
states to choose their own security
arrangements and alliances
we've addressed the possibility of
reciprocal transparency measures
regarding forced posture in ukraine as
well as measures to increase confidence
regarding military exercises and
maneuvers in europe
and we address other areas where we see
potential for progress
including arms control related to
missiles in europe
our interest in a follow-on agreement to
the new start treaty that covers all
nuclear weapons
and ways to increase transparency and
stability
we put these ideas forward because they
have the potential
if negotiated in good faith
to enhance our security and that of our
allies and partners
while also addressing russia's stated
concerns through reciprocal commitments
our response to russia reflects what i
said in kiev berlin and geneva last week
we're open to dialogue
we prefer diplomacy
and we're prepared to move forward
where there is the possibility of
communication cooperation
if russia de-escalates its aggression
toward ukraine stops the inflammatory
rhetoric
and approaches discussions about the
future security in europe in a spirit of
reciprocity
our responses were fully coordinated
with ukraine and our european allies and
partners with whom we've been consulting
continuously for weeks
we sought their input and incorporated
it into the final version delivered to
moscow
additionally
nato developed and will deliver to
moscow its own paper with ideas and
concerns about collective security in
europe and that paper fully reinforces
ours and vice versa
there's no daylight among the united
states and our allies and partners on
these matters
we shared our response paper with
congress
and i'll be briefing congressional
leaders on this later today
and consulting with them on our approach
as you know
there's strong bipartisan interests and
deep expertise on the hill when it comes
to ukraine and russia and we very much
appreciate having congress as a partner
as we move forward
we're not releasing the document
publicly because we think that diplomacy
has the best chance to succeed if we
provide space for confidential talks
we hope and expect that russia will have
the same view and we'll take our
proposal seriously
i expect to speak to foreign minister
lavrov in the coming days after moscow
has had a chance to read the paper and
is ready to discuss next steps
there should be no doubt about our
seriousness of purpose when it comes to
diplomacy
and we're acting with equal focus and
force
to bolster ukraine's defenses and
prepare a swift united response to
further russian aggression
three deliveries of u.s defensive
military assistants arrive in kiev this
week
carrying additional javelin missiles and
other anti-armor systems
283 tons of ammunition and non-lethal
equipment essential to ukraine's
front-line defenders
more deliveries are expected in the days
to come
we've provided more defensive security
assistance to ukraine in the past year
than in any previous year
last week i authorized u.s allies
including estonia latvia and lithuania
to provide u.s origin military equipment
from their inventories for use by
ukraine
also last week we notified congress of
our intent to deliver it to ukraine the
mi-17 helicopters currently held in
defense department inventories five
additionally the secretary of defense
announced on monday
that 8 500 u.s service members currently
stationed in europe and the united
states
have been placed in heightened readiness
of heightened readiness to deploy to
ensure that we're able to support the
nato response force swiftly if it's
activated by the north atlantic council
to harden the allies eastern flank
other nato allies have also announced
steps that they're prepared to take
and we expect more in the coming days
we've taken this step
out of prudence
we hope those forces don't have to be
activated for deployment
but if they are
we will be ready
we're also continuing to coordinate with
our european allies and partners on
severe economic sanctions to hold moscow
accountable for its actions
we've developed a high impact quick
action response that would inflict
significant costs on the russian economy
and financial system
as part of our response
we're also prepared to impose export
controls that will have a longer-term
effect
denying russia products that it needs to
fulfill its strategic ambitions
on top of all of that
our allies and partners are also
stepping up to provide assistance to
ukraine in various and mutually
reinforcing ways
as we've done many times before
the alliance and individual allies are
coming together to support our partners
and to defend what should be invaluable
principles that have helped provide
unprecedented security stability and
prosperity for decades in europe
and around the world
finally
we're looking to support our allies and
partners in dealing with the secondary
negative consequences of russia's
destabilizing acts
for example we know that ukraine's
economy and financial position is being
affected by this crisis
and just as we're bolstering ukraine's
security
so too are we looking for how we can
support its economy beyond the
significant assistance we're already
provided
our european allies and partners are
doing so as well
and that's another matter that i'll have
an opportunity to congress later this
afternoon
uh taking us to ensure that
uh the global energy supply isn't
disrupted uh that too is an important
focus should russia choose to weaponize
its natural gas by cutting supply to
europe even more than it's already done
we're in discussions with governments
and major producers around the world
about surging their capacity
we're engaged in detailed conversations
with our allies and partners about
coordinating our response including how
best to deploy their existing energy
stockpiles
all this effort is aimed at mitigating
price shocks
and ensuring that people united states
europe and around the world have the
energy they need no matter what russia
decides to do
all told
our actions over the past week
have sharpened the choice facing russia
now
we've laid out a diplomatic path
we've lined up steep consequences should
russia choose further aggression we've
stepped forward with more support for
ukraine's security and economy
and we and our allies and partners are
united across the board
now we'll continue to press forward and
prepare
it remains up to russia to decide how to
respond
we're ready either way
one final note before i take some
questions
regarding american citizens in ukraine
as you know earlier this week i
authorized the voluntary departure of a
limited number of u.s employees
and ordered the departure of many family
members of embassy personnel from
ukraine
this was a decision based on one factor
only
the safety and security of our
colleagues and their families
and given the continued massive buildup
of russian forces on ukraine's borders
which has many indications of
preparations for an invasion
these steps were the prudent ones to
take
i want to be clear that our embassy in
kyiv will remain open
and we continue to maintain a robust
presence to provide diplomatic economic
and security support to ukraine
the state department has also issued an
updated travel advisory due to the
potential for security conditions to
deteriorate rapidly and without warning
if russia invades or commits other
destabilizing actions inside ukraine
our message now for any americans
ukraine
is to strongly consider leaving
using commercial or other privately
available transportation options
these options remain readily available
and the embassy may extend loans to
those who can't afford the cost of a
commercial ticket
while the state department will always
seek to provide consular services
wherever possible
russian military action would severely
impact our ability to perform that work
and if russia invades civilians
including americans still in ukraine
could be caught in a conflict zone
between combatant forces
the us government may not be in a
position to aid individuals in these
circumstances
this has long been the case in conflict
zones around the world
so
while we don't know whether russia will
continue its aggression toward ukraine
either way we have a responsibility to
provide this notice to americans there
and with that happy to take some
questions
hi uh thank you mr secretary um i i i
realize that you don't want to get into
the specifics of what what is actually
in this document and uh although
i'm sure i and my colleagues will
continue to try to get them but can you
say more broadly when you say that there
are core principles that you're
committed to and
to uphold and defend
does that mean that in this document you
told the russians point blank in writing
that
no
is the answer to their demands for a
formal
bar on the expansion of nato the
permanent exclusion of ukraine
and the um
the withdrawal of certain forces and
equipment from eastern europe
is that what this says can is there
anything different in this document than
what we have heard publicly over the
course of the last couple weeks
uh again without going to the specifics
of the document i can tell you that it
reiterates what we've said
publicly
for many weeks and in a sense for many
many years
that
we
will uphold
the principle of nato's uh open door
um
and that's uh
as i've said repeatedly
in recent weeks
uh a commitment that uh that we're bound
to
and so
the document as i as i said
makes very clear some of the basic
principles that
we are standing by committed to uh and
will uphold
much of which uh has been stated in
public including by me in recent days
and weeks and that goes to nato's
open-door policy so you would say that
exactly
this isn't about concession well there
is no change in that in the u.s or nato
position
in this document
first of all uh there is uh there is no
change there will be no change second we
reiterate the that principle
uh of course
it is for nato uh not the united states
unilaterally to um
discuss uh the uh
the open door the open-door policy these
are decisions that nato makes as an
alliance not the united states
unilaterally but from our perspective
uh i can't be more clear
nato's door
is open remains open
and that is our commitment
do you have any reason to believe then
that the document that was submitted
will in any way
lessen the chance of russian action or
was this just to to show you tried
margaret
what um
what we do uh in this document
besides
laying out our core principles
besides sharing
our concerns concerns of allies and
partners
about uh
things that russia is doing that we
believe undermines security and
stability
uh we also do lay out areas where we
believe uh that
together we could actually advance
security for everyone including uh for
russia based on some of its stated
concerns uh as well of course is for us
and for our allies and partners and so
there are a number of areas again based
on what russia has said
uh that
i think would make a difference if
uh done on a reciprocal cases
and approaching good faith so for
example as we said uh the placement of
effect of offensive missile systems uh
in ukraine military exercises and
maneuvers
uh in europe
potential arms control measures uh
greater transparency
various measures to reduce risks
all of these things would address i
think mutual concerns including concerns
stated by russia
and advanced collective security so i
think there is um uh there there are
important things to work with if russia
is serious about working with them
uh and that is
up to uh up to president putin we'll see
how they respond but there's no there's
no doubt in my mind that if russia were
to approach this
seriously and in a spirit of reciprocity
with the determination to
enhance collective security for all of
us
there are
very positive things in this um
in this document uh that uh that should
be pursued
we can't make that decision
uh for president putin only he can make
we've said uh
throughout and we of course started this
process with the the conversations that
took place in our strategic stability
dialogue with russia between russia and
the united states about 10 days ago
at the nato-russia council
at the organization for cooperation
security in europe
um
that uh again we uh
we understand russia has stated concerns
about security we have
our own very clear concerns about
the security and the actions that
russia's taking that undermine it and we
are prepared to discuss and
if appropriate eventually negotiate
um steps to enhance
everyone's security
and i've laid out some of the areas
where we think uh we could do that but
right now
this is about the the areas uh and
and ideas that we could pursue
and we'll see how uh how russia responds
just buying time till they're in a place
to invade ukraine making you jump
through hoops like hand delivering
written responses to questions that
you've answered time and time again in
the past and meanwhile they're
destabilizing ukraine from within the
economy is crumbling you're spending
hundreds of millions of dollars showing
them up at what point do you stop
playing russia's game and take
pre-emptive action now
so ben um
first uh
we're as you know not uh not standing
still and we uh
can
walk and chew gum at the same time and
that's very much what we've been doing
so we've been
clear to russia
that there are two paths a diplomatic
one but also a path of
defense and and deterrence and if russia
chooses aggression uh a path that will
lead to massive consequences and so even
as we've been engaging in the diplomacy
which is my job and responsibility we
have been very resolutely preparing for
russia to take the other path the path
of aggression and as i laid out
the uh work that we've done over the
past couple of months in bringing allies
and partners together
around massive consequences for russia
should it renew its aggression
and the very detailed uh work that's
been done on that but that'll be sure
enough
um the
shoring up in very significant ways of
our support for ukraine including the
defensive military support the drawdown
of the president issued in december
uh which has now is now being delivered
uh to ukraine the additional steps um
to make sure that defensive military
assistance was being made available to
ukraine including the authorizations
that i signed a week ago to allow other
countries that have us original military
equipment
to uh to share it with ukraine
the work we're doing to bolster
ukraine's economy the work we're doing
to shore up
uh europe on energy if uh there are
disruptions as a result of conflict
and of course the uh
orders that the president gave secretary
of defense gave earlier this week uh to
make sure that we are fully prepared uh
on a moment's notice to reinforce nato's
eastern flank in the event of renewed
russian aggression all of those things
have been happening very deliberately
uh and uh and effectively over the last
many weeks so
these two paths and the approach that
we've taken these are mutually
reinforcing the work that we're doing on
defense on deterrence uh bringing allies
and partners together
i think reinforces our diplomacy
uh and at the same time it's very
important that we pursue uh the
diplomacy whether or not you may well be
right
russia is not serious about this at all
but we have an obligation to test that
proposition
to pursue the diplomatic path to leave
no diplomatic stone unturned because for
sure
it's far preferable to resolve these
differences
peacefully consistent with our
principles uh than it would be to uh to
have renewed regression renewed conflict
and everything that will fall from that
but the point is we're prepared either
way
hello mr secretary um i just want to ask
you a little bit about the unified
approach with uh with europe what do you
make of germany's stance for example
they ruled out sending lethal weapons to
ukraine they prevented estonia from
delivering arms and today there was news
out that they are sending helmets to
ukraine a delivery kiev mayor said was a
joke would you say that you're happy or
satisfied with germany sending helmets
to ukraine instead of arms shipments
and if i may just ask about president's
comments yesterday he said that he would
consider sanctioning putin personally if
he decides to invade how advanced are
these plans and then again going back to
unity with europe has the united states
discussed this with europe and are they
on board thank you
first let me let me say it's general
matter and i i
at the risk of patting ourselves on the
shoulder i have to say i was struck when
i spoke to the
foreign affairs council of the european
union a couple of days ago
that
partner after partner this was in the eu
context but i've heard the same thing at
nato
um
referenced the the word that was used
was unprecedented
coordination and consultation with
allies and partners
on
on this issue and on this challenge
and
one result of that unprecedented
coordination consultation is
as i see it
very strong solidarity in terms of the
consequences that will befall russia if
it renews aggression against ukraine
um and that is across the board
and that includes germany and i was just
in germany as
as you know very well uh meeting with uh
with chancellor schultz and spending a
lot of time with my german counterpart
foreign minister bareback
and um as i said before
i'm absolutely confident uh in german
solidarity in uh being with uh together
with us and other allies and partners
in confronting renewed russian
aggression uh against ukraine now look
different countries have different
authorities
they have different capabilities they
have different areas of expertise and
we're bringing all of those to bear but
doing it in a way that is complementary
uh and it speaks to the shared
commitment we have
to defend ukraine's territorial
integrity sovereignty
um and its uh and its independence
uh when it comes to sanctions i think as
as you heard uh the president say
uh everything is on the table i can tell
you this
the the steps that we will take
together
swiftly
will go directly to things that
president putin cares deeply about
including
russia's ability to engage uh
economically uh and uh and financially
including its ability uh to um develop
uh technology
uh for the uh
sectors that it cares most about uh like
defense like high tech and as the
president said
everything is on the table and i'll
leave it with them
a
um
from president biden to president putin
and if you can also shine a little bit
of light on president biden's role in
crafting this message
sure
um
kelly again uh
the the document that we've shared with
russia today is
does it does a few things
and first and foremost it uh states very
clearly uh the principles that we're
committed to
and that we will defend one way or the
other
second it lays out
our own concerns
and allied concerns about actions that
russia has taken is taken
is taking not just with regard to
ukraine but more broadly
in the european theater that we believe
undermine security
third it addresses
concerns that russia raised in the
document that it provided to us
a couple of weeks ago and finally
um
it suggests uh areas
where
based on uh reciprocity we believe uh we
could advance our collective security
again in ways that that address our
concerns and in ways that address some
of russia's concerns that's what this
does this it's not a formal negotiating
document
it's not uh
explicit
proposals it it lays out
the areas and some ideas
of how we can together if they're
serious
advance
collective security
president biden was uh intimately
involved in
in this
in this document
we've
reviewed it with him
repeatedly over the last weeks just as
we were getting as you know
comment uh input ideas from allies and
partners it was vital that we
work on this document even though it
goes
to bilateral
uh matters and what nato is providing
presumably goes to the uh some broader
issues that involved nato and russia
uh and but allies and partners were
intimately involved as well and we took
on board
uh many of the comments they've made and
integrated them into the document but
the president has been uh deeply
involved in this from from the get-go
reviewing
uh various drafts of the uh of the
proposal making his own edits uh and of
course uh blessing the final uh document
that was delivered to russia today
you know
biden himself
u.s fight and administration officials
have said a invasion is potentially
imminent the stakes are incredibly high
here and you guys have also said that
putin is the decision maker so why not
address this directly to him
given the situation you're facing right
now
i'm not sure what you mean by address it
directly to him this is a this is a
document that was
prepared
on behalf of the united states by its
government being delivered
to russia and to its government
upon which president putin presides i
have no doubt that
our russian counterparts and my
counterpart foreign minister lavrov
i will share the document with president
putin
and
putting putting things in perhaps
everyone else you may be right
and of course
it's these are
these are also complex
issues
and
putting things in writing is also a good
way as we do
all the time
across the board
is a good way to make sure we're as
precise as possible and the russians
understand our positions our ideas as
clearly as possible right now
the
uh document is with them and
the ball is in their court we'll see
what we do as i've said repeatedly
whether they choose the path of
diplomacy and dialogue whether they
decide to renew aggression against
ukraine
we're prepared either way thank you
thanks everyone
i